well so if
i take you on like a i don't know
10-year
fast-forward yeah and i paint a picture
of uh something today that seems
absolutely insane
but there's early signs that people are
building this and let's just give them
the benefit of the doubt that some of
the early iterations will work and some
of or most of them won't
there's a world where you and i are
participating in a digital economy
in a virtual world where uh whether it
is a piece of art
it is a digital sculpture it is a
digital
skin from a video game it is a digital
good
that we purchased somewhere online
and we bring it and we display it in a
digital museum or a virtual museum
and so now all of a sudden you can
charge people for entry
you can consign digital goods it's the
replication of what happens in the
analog world now just in digital
and when you do that what you do is you
take
the addressable markets of these assets
or these mechanisms
and they explode in the digital realm
and so now all of a sudden
how fast does the human race
accelerate when it comes to human
production
intelligence learning all in the digital
output
let's just if i said to you 20 years ago
i'm going to give you a global education
it means i'm going to take you and i'm
going to physically move you
to geography after geography after
geography it's going to take time
it's going to take resources and
ultimately it's going to take lots of
effort
if i now said to you hey i'm going to
transport you
in this virtual world to multiple
geographies
but you're going to experience it in
this virtual
world and you're going to have digital
goods that you can take
from economy to economy or from location
to location
all of a sudden you may get maybe you
get 90 percent of the value you don't
get 100 of the same value we get 90
of the value but you can do it at a much
faster pace
and so in a six-month period you've
actually made three times the progress
than you would have if you had to do in
the physical world so that's where i
think we're heading
so so there's digital art being
displayed in the digital
museum and people are being charged for
access and perhaps we plug in our senses
which means we start to operate more and
more in a virtual reality
augmented reality virtual reality way
with this digital world
and increasingly go into this world
basically
lived most of our productive and uh
social lives in this digital world
uh and increasingly essentially create a
simulation
uh where the biological basis is just
there to say sustain the brain that's
used to operate in the
in the virtual world uh taking us back
to the original when we started talking
about war
i wonder what conflict looks like in
that world
that uh the people who are born today
maybe will be fighting wars
in the space in in that museum world
in that digital world remember what i
said we're moving from a world
of conflict surrounded and determined by
bombs bullets and soldiers to a
battlefield that is determined by
war of information and cyber
capabilities
and so in that virtual world is it about
death and destruction of human life
in the physical analog world or will it
become more important to
attack or defend virtual property
and virtual life and you know some level
of virtual sovereignty
in my opinion the latter is more likely
and so what you start to understand is
well
what do you truly value in your life
is it the physical analog materialistic
consumptive goods or is it virtual
and in many cases something as simple as
the ability to connect with somebody
is really important and so one of the
most disruptive
combative violent things that a country
may do to another country in the future
simply take down the internet
and put people in isolation yeah i don't
need to physically harm you if i can
psychologically harm you
i don't need to terrifying yeah i don't
need to
uh actually convince you
through a monopoly on violence on
physical violence
what if i can psychologically change the
way you see the world
through misinformation through all sorts
of
nefarious activities and i think that
you know the united states has been
struggling with this idea over the last
couple of years in the political arena
but what happens when it starts to come
to other aspects of our life
you